what's going on reject nation greg and
john here we're gonna watch today
by popular demand and i hope everyone
has put a comment down asking us to
check it out is watching this video
today cuz the pressure worked
superman and lois the pilot so guys if
you go ahead hit that like button
subscribe and click the notification
bell doing any of those will actually
really help out the algorithm with
getting this video seen to more people
especially considering how late we are
to it and also the reason we were
hesitant is because
i'm not that caught up to date with the
arrowverse like i've seen all of arrow i
saw the first five seasons of flash saw
first season
dc's legend tomorrow and i've seen all
the crossovers i'm obviously not up to
date but everyone assured me that
we don't need to be that we can just go
into this
as it is and have some familiarity with
like yeah there's
superman lowest exists in the world
that's about all you need to know i'm
going in with that mentality all you
guys said i didn't need to worry about
that
that's awesome but guys this is reaction
highlights full interaction watch along
where you sync up with the time coders
all over at our patreon page thank you
so much everyone who has followed us for
2021 so far
we cover so many shows we're at the same
tier you get the option for reaction
highlights and watch along included
either or for so many of these shows i'm
showing up on screen right now i hope i
successfully edited this to get it up on
tuesday before episode 2 came out
so that way we at least got the pilot
out of the way
all right let's do it
[Music]
i remember coming to this earth feeling
the sun on my face for the first time
why did you say that i thought i'd live
there forever
no poor papa can't damn tornado took him
out
eventually i moved to metropolis
[Music]
cool costume thanks my mom made it for
me
i've never met a clark before never met
a lois before
actually there was my first grade
teacher lois hannigan so i guess
technically oh
technically technically you're a liar i
told lois who i really was
where i came from
[Music]
then lois proposed to me
[Laughter]
took a lot of initiative oh cool
nice damn this is like super cinematic
quality level
cw competing with cable now
jonathan was easy no name after the dad
things with jordan were more challenging
finally the prequel
ace chemical but do they know they're
their dentist what's elaine is that her
dad yeah
he was at the wedding
cool
superhero landing
yeah this looks so good
i know this looks so good and he's
really well cast
we had a superman show dude [ __ ]
just hit me
yo you'd be a great bartender dude
they are stepping up the quality
[Music]
love that ice is melting the closer he
gets
[Music]
that's my son-in-law that's my
except i can't tell anyone that
let's face it 90 of the audience is here
to see lois lane
boom look at that shot
god there must be so many people in
metropolis or like what
was that it's a bird i'm
actually starting qb i think i'm the
first freshman to ever do it and some of
the upperclassmen are
pretty ticked off oh don't worry about
them you got super powers
take advantage just try not to rip
anybody's hands
um oh
great thank you okay thanks such a dad
oh awesome awesome yes
i'm almost done with injustice too this
close make a pretty good superman
this man's boring i'm raiden
huh um to hell with you you're not my
son
laser [ __ ]
your dad yeah
music and dad superman sucks so you know
i've never met him i want to give a [ __ ]
it's the worst thing i'm moving to
gotham dad
it's so weird to be almost done with
injustice 2 the same night watch batman
v superman ultimate edition and then the
next afternoon going to this show
it's like that's so different superman
in my head superman
you really do need to be around more i
do have a responsibility to the world as
you know who mainly voldemort sorry
metropolis you okay i just need to lie
down that's all
no doctor donner seagull oh
cool awesome
i love you guys love you luck today guys
next time
superman sucks
doesn't mean he has powers have you seen
him throw a deep route and what about
jordan all he's gonna do is make him
feel more alien than he already does
hmm ironic say the wrong thing to one
person
the whole world knows who i am or if i
take off my glasses
your father agrees with me oh now we
care what my dad thinks
oh damn more layoffs i knew when morgan
edge want the planet there'd be cuts but
this is unbelievable you got a minute
i gotta say i really like the pacing and
the tone so far yeah
hey mom sorry this morning's just been
dr frye no oh no
whoa whoa
oh no what
damn i did not expect that
first episode huh
that was a great match
you know it's really heartbreaking but i
love the possibilities that direction
opens up
who's that lana i'm gonna guess lana
i'm gonna guess it's lana remember that
girl from that summer we stayed here
she's here
billy where 50 yards and approaching
that's football talk 50 yards
go to the deep end go long
[Laughter]
that's catcher to see you honestly it is
lana yeah i'm a hero
i'm really sorry about your grandma even
my dad liked her and he hates everyone
so it's an interesting beat a house full
of girls
someone's always pissed at you
this guy like a piece of [ __ ] or
something i can't make a
family life like that's why daddy got
mad when we saw you on his facebook page
oh he is a he's got a temper
a little worried about this guy i could
really use a drink
actually now you're talking yes i want a
lot of drinks
[Laughter]
what's in the barn our dad doesn't like
us in there he says it's full of stuff
that can kill us
well as a member of the ffa i think i
can keep you guys safe
future farmers you little [ __ ] you're
gonna uncover it all
set off a chain reaction no breitbart
he doesn't age it's a good genes i guess
he's like 32 since we were in high
school he aged
just to a degree you know it used to be
that uh when folks move away to get
their degrees
well they bring their skills back home
take care of the communities help raised
him you know that ain't happening
anymore
his mom just died you [ __ ] morgan
edge ruins everything he touches people
quit reading that paper because uh
your reporters can't keep your politics
to yourself
lana what's he talking about your mother
had some business with us
it's all what the hell lana we're only
here for a few days
and i figured that we kind of need
someone to show us around okay
uh phone oh no not you yeah
you
whoa it's coming of age independent
sofia coppola movie
lost in kryptonian found the router
how was grandma thinking putting it up
there i got it
power reveal jordan be careful oh
sweetie's gonna fall and be okay yeah
or he dies too it's hereditary
[Laughter]
death runs in the family i heard her say
something as i was flying here
what yeah this is a terrible setup
this is exactly what your dad was
warning you about the pipes
you might try to get to the router and
slide on some pipes that you fall off
and then it'll fall on you
i love how he ran normally hey man
people are watching well aware
i can't see them anymore it was his idea
oh i love the music yeah a little han
zimmery come on boys let's get upstairs
you've had a long day
i'm thinking of driving more pipes on
this
it's pretty impressive right what else
could you survive being having dropped
maybe you should start thinking about
how sarah cushing gave you her digits
and not me
you texted her already didn't you
amateur yeah you're supposed to wait six
weeks let's
do it right away
you sent a waving hand emoji you know
what that is a vulcan salute i gotta say
that's that's even worse she just sent
me a nudie pic john
she's an art john
something we're not being told about and
it's up to us to find out what that is
whatever weirdo sure i've never noticed
my
really strong throwing abilities
good thing kryptonian sperm is
compatible with yeah human eggs it's
good didn't rip her apart
it's kryptonian you are not a hero
kal-el
whoever did this knows who i am yeah
i don't know
a lot of cow elves
there is a powerful something out there
that doesn't like superman when there's
a problem you will be there for them but
right now this family needs you more
hmm damn lois laying down she wears the
pants
you need to get rid of her coraco
superman doesn't get to have a normal
life no matter how much you want one for
it or yourself
jesus he's like all team superman
[Laughter]
she's got to get her priorities straight
yeah i'm an interesting flipping dynamic
you can either repay the loan or
you can accept a healthy buyout for the
remaining value of the property
no no
oh hell no can't leave the kent
farm come on no you're superman steal
some [ __ ]
steal some money and bring into a bank
vault
you could do it without a trade besides
how do you get them up off of us so fast
anyway dad can't put up a christmas tree
without falling off the ladder
just dad's never been injured or had to
go to the doctor
jordan what are we looking for anyways
an alien spaceship
i found a dead body back here want to
poke you hear that
the poles just probably shifted the
floor huh
all things considered it seems really
easy to find
khalel's kryptonian ship
yeah we've come a long way since the
camouflaging powers of hay
[Laughter]
this may have worked in smallville back
in the day
at least made it some type of lock
sequence eventually sometimes
entering a code it's probably grandpa's
old tool storage or something back up
tools
what an annoying spot to keep your tools
go up that ladder
let me go deep into the valves of the
earth to get my circular saw
too dangerous to keep above the surface
something toss it up
[Laughter]
whoa what are you doing do not touch
that
oh my god did you see that
jump in it he's gonna get sucked in jump
in it
oh
whoa whatever it is not from kansas
but that girl ever texts you back that's
what i've been waiting for this whole
time
i mean i knew you'd find this [ __ ] but
what's going on with that girl dude
you're gonna have a first date or what
why would my mom want me to come home
just to sell the phone this is like a
sci-fi
drama i know it's so cool
you're getting both you're getting the
intrigue and the actual like character
drama you may have super strength and
super hearing but i have super smell on
those loans don't smell right
yeah which needed super money
super financing i do have super small
by the way i just don't use it very
often you know
that was two teenage boys in the house
two very upset teenagers what the hell
is the spaceship there's crystals
yes okay it was a lie hmm
[Laughter]
you're saying you're a superman no i've
seen superman before we've seen him
i have a video game
i can show you right now
[Music]
oh wow they're working with the glasses
thing
i guess oh no they're just
gonna be more than i thought it was
gonna be like the glasses are off oh my
god you're right
who are you where did my dad go
[Music]
all that adrenaline
oh our dad's the coolest
hard to answer i'm sorry i said superman
sucked earlier dad
i wanna always play superman now oh he's
crying all the excuses
you made me think i was crazy they put
me up bills i knew what kind of burden
it would be if you both had powers or
worse if
one of you had them and the other one
didn't
you think he's the reason we survived
yesterday go tell superboy here why it's
really so perfect oh
man you wouldn't have it any other way
would you then oh
god you sure as hell weren't sent here
to be a father oh
jordan ouch laser him courtney
blow his head up some discipline or
freeze him at the very least
feels like it's my fault that this is
all falling apart your life falling
apart doesn't mean you're special it
means you're human
that's great that's a good line so much
meaning right now
i know you're here and i know you can't
see me
led light engagements troublesome bruin
i bet it's like lex luthor
or brainiac i'm gonna go luther on this
one
i eventually arrived here where i
learned you were here too
[Laughter]
great speed ramp not as fast as i
thought
master chief
i don't know who that is you're not the
only one you know
on something you for what my heroine
addiction
she's a firefighter and being a
firefighter here parents
cooking meth and the whole house
catching on fire with
their kids inside smallville wow
a long way from americana i took a bunch
of my mom's pills
my mom she made a really big drama out
of it for a sad story it's really basic
dude he looks like he's falling he
weighs in love with you he wants to kiss
you right now
oh what are you doing what hey
trauma bond it's my girlfriend
sean what the hell is your how are you
doing
[Music]
whoa he's at the party too yeah where
did he come from i'm superman
you
you're going to cave that dude's skull
in
oh they all got their phones out oh
actually pretty tense right now this is
so cool
i am in love with this oh this is great
damn
i'm so happy we're watching this right
what a great ass
now that's america's egg
really stood out in that shot
oh he's bleeding
oh he's resorting to lasers
he's got a whole suit that's foolproof
to take on superman
oh [ __ ]
you're still that scared lost desperate
for the love of people that will never
accept you
what have you done little boy
kryptonite make you sick no
ow
who is this [ __ ]
i want to know
maxie i gotta go that's good thing they
were on the news
[Laughter]
no
[Music]
he's really good at that quick change
lucky's family i know thank you
[Music]
screw your wife's paper
thanks for giving me all the powers dad
what do you think you need some eye
drops jordan
[Laughter]
powers are manifesting very differently
than mine did
but we're gonna look so evil that's a
villain shot
yeah i hate having powers i hate not
having powers i hate having powers
i hate it all
i mean if i was jock brother i'd be more
upset like i worked my ass off how does
her powers
yeah you mean i'm just good at throwing
you think your mom wanted us to move to
smallville and live on the farm it's a
simpler life
i know it would be a huge huge change
but worst case i can
fly you over wherever you need to go
he's flight or work in the morning i
think she was right
[Music]
really
i really hope it's not just the pilot
that shot this good i know
okay we gotta throw everything out of it
so we could get picked up
i haven't always been there for you but
i promise you
from now on i will be especially not v
got powers
i'm gonna be right there you're my
favorite son now
[Music]
oh thank god it ends on a nice note with
them who was that guy though that was
i know who's master chief we're thinking
of reopening the farm
i run it the way my folks and i used to
back in the day
so you're saying my husband this is not
gonna be
not going to be cool why would someone
like morgan edge be interested in a
bunch of family farms in smallville
kansas
very good question that's the question
someone should investigate
do some journalism i'm just really sorry
about how it all went down
you should have mentioned something you
could have mentioned yeah
no powers are overrated anyways this
just
uh confirms what i've known to be true
all along yeah yeah
my skills on the field that
kid is really naturally charming
he does seem to be like the cha like the
grandson of jonathan ken what would you
guys think about staying here a little
longer
we just wanted to give you both some
time to process well until then you two
follow me out to the barn i want to show
you a few things
superman things like how to attach a
plow to a tractor dad we have questions
we just found out our dad's superman i
mean
thousands of questions
this is so touching i know oh [ __ ]
hell yeah show
hell yeah who are you
it's tom from toonami we also need
kryptonite
that was the last of your supply then
we'll have to go get
i'll start the upgrade is it lex luthor
captain luthor it is lex luthor damn
damn what's funny is uh luther
john cryer plays him in supergirl and
some of the crossovers
and so it just looks like they're really
doing their own things
so not john crime tell you that
it's john cryer doing blackface people
that's what twenty-twenty
show was going so well so john cryer
showed up in blackface
yeah i mean that was a freaking that was
that was awesome
i really enjoyed that that was awesome
as mentioned like it's been consuming so
much dc content lately i'm i'm this
close to finishing injustice 2.
this close playing the story mode when i
decided to eat dinner i just put on
batman v superman ultimate edition
which is freaking phenomenal by the way
like if you weren't a fan of bvs but if
you watch the ultimate edition
that is great yeah now i'm checking out
this other version of superman my third
version of superman in 48 hours and uh i
gotta say
that i will very much impress i fell off
those cw shows kind of for a reason
and this is one or i could definitely
see myself getting really
hooked into it the things of the way it
started off in the beginning i'm like
well from what i remember learning this
seems
different so i feel like they're kind of
just doing their own thing now like you
have the actors you brought over but it
just feels like its own fresh reboot
what i love about it especially is
something that i think filmmakers have a
difficult time with
with superman is finding ways to make
the character
complex to find real conflict for him to
deal with something that is relatable
conflict
and i think they really found it where
you can have
kind of a darker approach yet still
keep him with the personality of clark
can't slash superman that we're all
familiar with
and add a natural layer of complexity by
the fact of how
he doesn't know how to balance working
life being a dad
while also being superman kind of giving
him something like peter parker
i know it's a different this is marvel
but it's kind of a peter parker thing it
was reminding me of
a guy who's just trying to have a
personal life but is struggling with it
while also trying to balance being a
superhero
i mean that's more than just peter
parker but having that applied here with
superman i think is a fresh angle to go
down with him on because yeah this show
has
a lot of weight on the drama it's pacing
and tone it's not as lively or
upbeat yet it still feels like superman
you know which i thought was great as
much as like the cinematography feels
honestly feels very snyder influenced
by just how darkly lit everything is
like it's super cinematic
but it's also very darkly lit throughout
but i personally thought that they quite
nailed it and like
the kids i wasn't really giving two
shits about at first but
as time went on i found myself caring
about what was going on with them so
i do gotta say that uh in terms of a
pilot yeah you got a viewer here who
wants to see how this all goes
yeah absolutely this hooked me really
well and i thought that they did a nice
job of spreading it around because you
do get your superman
action you get to watch him do some cool
stuff with his powers and you know help
out with some really big crisis
situations but then they also yeah
compelled me with the family drama the
stuff with the kids the small
town angle and the attitudes as much as
we were joking about that scene when
they're you know meeting with uh
lana and her husband you know like some
of those ideas about you know
people leave they go and they learn
things they're supposed to bring them
back
you know like i thought they did a nice
job of establishing a personal character
story
throwing in some you know real world
allegorical content and then throwing
yeah this new family angle
and expanding on what already exists
with you know the john kang character
and that was the part of the episode i
thought
would lose me the most and then it ended
up really sucking me in i thought they
had a nice
and a very a cinematic balance of
character moments
that breathed and didn't seem like they
were trying to get to anything or rush
through anything
it felt like at a really natural pace
you know yeah
that's probably the most surprising part
to me is because when i saw the trailer
that's what i was
thinking it felt like but i had my
doubts in the back of my head of going
but it's the cw show
it's probably super fast-paced and kind
of cheesy
yeah yeah so that's why like i was
saying they're in this about hope the
rest of the
season maintains this type of pacing
maintains this type of tone because
i actually was really pulled into the
drama like the
the personal life drama like having to
deal with the mortgages
and what to do with the kent farm
because we're at a point now with
superman and and some other superheroes
out there but i think especially
superman that
we know how much the kent farm means to
clark kent like we
we don't need to do a whole thing on it
like we know we can fill in the blank on
that
you know even if you haven't seen
supergirl or any other previous episodes
or something by this point you're
probably someone who's like oh yeah no
that's the key this is getting farm
that's where
this alien was raised this is where he
developed his personality growing up
here in smallville how much
is important to him having to deal with
the conflict of what do we do with the
home
and how this also ties in with the
morgan edge character i think is neat
it's funny how and i know they're not at
all the same creative executives behind
it but how wonder woman 1984 had maxwell
lord who's
media mogul and then you have morgan
edgin here
same thing super rich guy super villain
media mogul
who they're setting up to be this
villain and then on top of that too now
you have luther being introduced in here
who seems like an alternate version of
lex luthor because
like from not so much of my knowledge
from the comics but from watching a lot
of the dc animated movies playing the
games
i'll often see lex luthor in his war
suit so it was like that might be him
in his war suit but just the whole
approach to him seems like he's from a
different earth there is that whole
history with lexor before
that i'm not super familiar with the
most basic of knowledge about that
planet that he helped out they
eventually named the planet after him
might not be that it could be infinite
crisis that they're pulling from
either way it seems like we're also
going to get a refreshing take
on lex luthor who's not just really
smart genius level businessman who has a
vendetta against superman for whatever
purpose the vibe i'm getting
is that wherever this luther is from
whatever universe he's from
who's somehow i'm getting the impression
he got slapped together with this earth
wherever he's from superman is a baddie
and he's a good guy
and i think that would be a fascinating
rich additional layer to add to this
show
to get that flipparoo he seems like he
really views superman as a villain who
wronged him in some way yeah he doesn't
seem like a
an ultimate baddie yeah that's just the
vibe i'm getting i'm not sure be curious
to know your theories
correct me that's something i think is a
neat hook at least again as
of this pilot not knowing what anything
is going to blossom into it seems like
they have
made a melding of both very classic
superman flavors and themes and then
also
some alternate takes or some takes that
would differ from the things we're very
used to seeing by now
yeah and i think too with the jordan
character
it could be going down a super boy prime
path
or as i call it the bright burn path uh
it just seemed like
it just seemed like they're really
setting him up to go evil superman
yeah those close-ups man well he's just
such a
moody kid and he's got what was social
anxiety disorder so he's got mental
health conditions but it seems like it's
it goes far beyond social anxiety
disorder it seems like he's got
possibly like suicidal tendencies like
he's got a lot happening with him and it
just seems like no matter
what is thrown at him he hates it or is
mad at her rebels against her is upset
by
much of hearing you there's a lot of
fear and anger
and uh depression and it's kind of
interesting to see how this show is
sort of acknowledging that straight on
like with the girl he was interested in
and hearing her backstory with
overdosing on her mother's pills
and then uh you know involving that
other side of smallville i thought was
neat too you do kind of get those
impressions of of
of some smaller towns in the united
states and around the world
of like yeah it's naturistic it's
peaceful mountain vibes country life
yet somehow there seems to be kind of
this
like cold depression that that looms in
a lot of these areas
you know it's someone who uh constantly
associates smallville as like
the plucky good-natured town you know
that clark kent was from
with that had that's high school bullies
that's kind of the vibe i always got
to see this side where you're dealing
with mental health i wonder how
how far down the road they'll go with
exploring because it just went to like
jordan's got super powers
so i don't know how far they'll go but
it seems like even at the discovery of
the powers
where he seems to brighten up the most
is him identifying
with this sarah sarah is her name i
think it's sarah
on the depression and the pain which is
a very
teenager dark love thing to do at the
same time
in terms of a character for a show i'm
like i don't know if that's a good sign
this kid has power
yeah yeah i don't know i i was sitting
here partly wondering if they might even
try and switcheroo us or something like
that because jonathan seems so suited
to being like superboy and taking after
his father and
maybe they'll throw a curveball our way
or something where it's you set it up to
be
jordan's gonna be the jealous one but i
don't know maybe
as jordan's powers manifest it's not
going to be as
nice of a situation i can see john being
super boy and then jordan being super
boy prime
well yeah kind of a cane and able
situation between them like the most
obvious paths go down
yeah i am concerned about the jordan
character though i know they're taking a
realistic approach
with him or they're doing their best to
take as much of a realistic authentic
approach with him
i can see him being a character that
just kind of gets on my nerves and a lot
of other people's nerves too
if they keep him on one note for the
show yeah like that's a character that's
easy to kind of
push into the one note and i think that
they have at least in this episode done
nicely to
at least the last half of this episode
did a lot of savings yeah where it's
like okay there are
dark and dour undertones to various
aspects of this but there are the
bonding moments too
yeah because i really like the brotherly
relationship between john
and jordan because they're twins but
john is like a little older
by like seconds or minutes either way he
embodies the older brother role so i
think that's really cool to have kind of
they're both twins yet one does feel
like a younger brother
while the other feels like the
protective older brother
through that there were some charms that
came out it was an interesting
debate pose of whether or not clark
should tell his kids that he is superman
or that he has these powers
they mentioned that he went back to the
fortress to solid i think they set a
fortress of solitude
they said it was unlikely so i was like
yeah maybe that maybe you don't have to
mention
to them that they have powers and wait
till they're adults or something like
that and as far as when the reveal
did come out their reactions seemed
like yeah that makes sense to me like i
think they really care about honoring
or at least capturing uh some more
realistic
tones and approaches to this world that
is fantasy that is
sci-fi it's a superman show at the end
of the day like i'm just giving the
credit to the drama
what's weird is from what i've seen of
lois in like the crossovers and the
other
and the snippets i've seen of like
supergirl and stuff i really like her
in that and then here didn't even have
much of the charm
of her that i've a little more
accustomed to it's still superman on
lois
so while i thought her scenes were still
acted well for the purpose of what they
wanted to execute in the pilot i thought
were done well
i am hoping that if you're gonna call
your show superman and lois that lois
feels more like a character i want to
see more of
not just the mom who's in between all
the more interesting characters
yeah yeah that was maybe one complaint i
might levy is just i thought she did a
really great job i liked their chemistry
a lot i liked her scenes a lot but it
did feel like
superman much rather than superman and
lois like superman and the super boys
yeah exactly and so i would hope that
she gets some plot lines that directly
center around her so that she's not just
always a support for a show where
they're both front and center in the
title i guess i would like
her to shine and have her own you know
focus a little bit more
yeah i mean she doesn't seem like a weak
character at all and i do think the
performance is still good i
just really does feel like this really
wasn't much about her
no no which is fine for now i just hope
as the show goes on it does
because i think lois lane is can often
be a character that can be hard to keep
really engaging and i think that when
done properly she can be
yeah we'll see where it goes i don't
know if you guys disagree with us on
that let us know anyway guys
superman lois episode one i thought this
was a wonderful pilot man i hope the
show stays this good i still managed to
capture that sense of wonder during
certain scenes and it really did make me
care about the family in the end
all right guys we'll subscribe click
that notification bell hit that like
button
last but not least
uh this one's easy michael b michael b
omni media who is uploading constantly
and he's also covering superman and lois
as
well the guy is a huge huge humungo
dc fan so please do yourself a favor
he covers a lot of dc content follow him
today on his channel
omni media he has awesome commentary
wonderful personality i mean it
sincerely he's just a good friend of
mine
michael thank you so much for your
support for all this time hopefully we
can do another collab and work together
properly in the future
catch you soon buddy
you